There's more to life than being pretty.
There is more to you
than how attractive you are to the rest of the world.
Your sole focus in life should not be
to be more consumable,
to be more digestible to people.
You are a full human being
and just because you don't fit some narrow,
narrow minded belief of what is and isn't beautiful
does not make you worth any less,
does not make you have any less value.
You are perfect in the body that you have.
You are perfect in the way that you look.
And the only person,
the only opinion
that matters on your body and your appearance
is your own.
You deserve to be happy exactly as you are
because you are perfect exactly as you are.